what's going on everybody it is your man
dr. Weil America's number one leadership
life trainer and you are joining me for
50 days of genius this is my gift to you
to provide you with 50 of my amazing
friends their inspiration and
motivational stories of how they're
succeeding in life several years ago I
wrote the book genius potential and in
this book I talk about the concept of
the everyday genius and who is the
everyday genius the everyday genius is
the person that has tapped into their
uniqueness they constantly are
developing their uniqueness and they're
sharing it with the world now when I say
sharing it with the world I don't mean
these people are per se traveling over
to Europe and Asia and places like that
many of my guests are doing that but
what I'm talking about is they have
decided to make an impact right where
they are right in their world they've
decided to make an impact and my guest
today is making a huge impact a huge
splash he is the renowned Evan
Carmichael how are you my friend welcome
to 50 days of genius good my man what's
going on man I'm just so honored to have
you here with us today let me first say
before we get in here man when I moved I
lived in Europe for 15 years before I
moved here to Phoenix Arizona and when I
moved back and I was building my
platform Evan Carmichael calm what was
and still is one of the platforms that I
use to get my message out so I want to
thank you man for setting up that
platform for all of us to use man I
constantly add articles on there and the
way you promote entrepreneurs and the
way you push us and the way you motivate
us man you're a huge part of what I'm
doing today in the success i have today
so let me say thank you on don's at my
man I love it man i gotta bring you with
me everywhere those intros any time an
awesome offer well so Evan the 50 days
of genius is all about people who have
tapped into their uniqueness and their
impact in the
world and like I said earlier not so
much that you're travelling global but
you are but people are just that are
passionate and you are very passionate
about helping entrepreneurs succeed how
did that come about it came about
because I sucked as an entrepreneur I
had my first company yeah I was 19 and I
mean you know up until that point I know
whatever I whatever I tried whoever I
applied myself I would get results you
know in school and sports whatever I put
in the work and get the results and i
had a company when i was 19 and uh man i
never worked so hard at anything I was
you know I don't know what the language
the kid I watch my language on your show
here but you know i was i was working
hard man every single day and just I
wasn't getting results like it was
insanely frustrating and was just it
took a huge toll on my self-confidence
my self-worth you know I felt like a
total failure and I know a lot of
entrepreneurs go through that every
entrepreneur goes through that and
nobody talks about it nobody talks how
hard it is being entrepreneur you just
see the guys doing well and and you
think man I'm going to be like that guy
and then you start and and you realize
just think something's wrong with you
because mcenroe results and so once i
went through that battle and figured it
out i wanted to share with others that
they didn't have to go through the same
thing that I did and so what I'm what
I'm curious about because a lot of
people if they don't play the piano if
they don't sing if they're not an artist
/ say they overlook their genius how did
you find out that just encouraging
people like you have a great gift of
encouragement like you live and breathe
encouragement how did you tap into that
to know that you can monetize that part
of your genius there's a lot in there
are one you are an artist man i'm an
artist i'm not but i can't play a little
piano you know i play a little piano but
you know i'm not you don't want to hear
me sing uh but I'm an artist and I apply
my art every day in what I do and for
everybody even watching this show you
know
lock the wheels and artists all you are
artists just got to tap into what you
want to create an amazing that for me
believe came my parents you know if I
walls it's on my back it's on everything
i do when i was growing up i know i
wasn't the best at school you know my
sisters were all getting straight A's
and I'm getting you no seas and at the
had my conversation every report card
time with my parents and they sit me
down and instead of just give me a hard
time they'd always tell me that I macos
truly Carmichael my mom's lastly
misconstrue Lee and I could do anything
and they make me believe in myself and
that's kind of the origin story for me
and and I believe in people I believe in
others I want people to bust through
their limiting beliefs I want people to
do amazing things with their life I
don't want people to live you know for
the evenings weekends I want people to
feel fulfilled I want to do something
that they are excited about the lens
which I can do that is entrepreneurship
because I have experience there if it
wasn't if I know how to be an
entrepreneur I'd be believing in people
doing something else but that that's
what fires me up man human potential I
mean I know we're on the same wavelength
i know this is what your show you know
the 50 days a genius Eugene's potential
is all about the same concepts where a
line there man but I hate seen potential
isn't wasting away in people and that's
ninety five percent of America and
people wake up and they drive to a job
but they hate just can't wait for
quitting time to come and not that sucks
man because life is so much more
beautiful than that you know that's
amazing because you're probably one of
the few people that I find that can
rival with a my my belief in that that
everybody can be genius everybody has
that genius and when I look at you I'm
like I don't know anybody too many other
people who just breathe motivation and
breathe disbelief but you do because I
honestly believe that you know my
t-shirts are kind of the same way live
genius because average is no fun right
so when you when you are going around
the world and you're sharing this
message what is the reception are people
starting to get it are they starting to
believe in themselves
huh yeah absolutely i think there's a
mix of people i think there's some
people who are ready to hear the message
i think there are people who've been
beat down for so long and and you know
they have this inkling that man i'm just
meant for more than what i'm doing right
now like this is this is not the best
version of me that I'm living right now
and those people are ready to hear the
message and they stupid and you know and
I'm sure you've seen a lot of people
who've read your book and watch your
show I listen to you regularly like the
people who are ready to hear the message
man they can transform their lives in a
second and they just need some some
little push some little guidance
motivation and that's our jobs man
that's what we got to do and provide and
that's how we make the world a better
place our genius that's what words
happening to I think there are others
who aren't who aren't quite ready to
hear the message yet you know they
they're in an environment that sucks
they've been told the whole life but
that they don't have any town they don't
have any genius they don't believe in
themselves that's a lot of people man's
a lot of people who don't have parents
who are supportive as mine were who you
know who didn't have a boss that tried
to make them better who you know have
friends who aren't doing anything
excited in their lives and so they hope
they hold themselves back and and they
don't have anybody in their lives who
believe that they can be more than what
they are now and in fact a lot of the
people in their last just tear them down
and get a new idea for what they wanted
to like I want to tap into my genius I
want to go and do this great thing and
then their friends are you and cream
that you know you didn't go to school
for that you know the money is I know
the skills do that and so like they've
heard that message so many times and now
they tell themselves that same message
in your ear that they need a little more
time to to be able to hear the messages
and change their environment to get to
the place where they can actually take
lunch so let me ask you this how did you
get to the point where even or your
website you named it Evan Carmichael now
I know what Evan Carmichael means today
in our space but when you were just
getting started before the Forbes
article before ain't you no name g one
of the top one
Andrea how did you know that just naming
your website Evan Carmichael was going
to be enough how did you get over that
hesitation of like are people really
gonna respond or am i this big guy with
this ego I'm gonna name it Evan
Carmichael yeah I didn't you know I wish
I had it all planned out and it's worked
out nicely for me but I didn't you know
the audience the honest truth is I sold
my company when I was 22 my first
company and I got asked to do a bunch of
speaking around the world you know young
entrepreneur success story kind of thing
and I put up the website just as a home
for me to see where i was speaking like
hey I'm going to be in Mexico or hey I'm
going to be in age or whatever it is
that's why it's a personal site it was
just Evan the speaker and then I started
out in content my own stories like okay
famous entrepreneur I love Marlon
success a love famous entrepreneur
stories I loved happening to their
wisdom and so I started sharing that on
the site and and then people started
writing to me said hey can I contribute
to the site you know I'm a business
coach try my marketing expert and I'm a
PR consultant I like to add content to
your website and I said sure why not you
know it's lots of value add and it just
kind of spiraled and then I thought I
made a big mistake like I named it out
to myself you know I wish I called it
entrepreneur resources com or small
business tips com or something uh and
and then only later I realize you know
what actually was a huge it was a huge
win that I didn't go that route that I
put it off my name because my company is
a constant reflection of Who I am and I
think it's so easy front repairs get box
into doing the same thing over and over
and over again and that even if they've
had success of that success becomes an
anchor that ransom from going forward
and doing something else and your
business needs to constantly reflect who
you are and so I'm super grateful that
that worked out but I didn't have a big
plan for it when I started and then I
thought I made the biggest mistake ever
by putting off my name and now I'm super
grateful for it so I wish I could say I
had it all planned out and it was all
you know part of my master plan but I
had no idea man no idea so let's talk
about that because just like you I read
a lot of the personal
books and I read a lot of the great
stories that Walt Disney's and a lot of
people didn't have a plan their plan was
just to do how powerful is action how
powerful is just not overthinking it and
doing believing how powerful is that
yeah I think you need to create to
create I think too many people try to
find an opportunity and they're just
chasing dollars and it never comes you
know like you can pick up inked magazine
and find 100 hardest 100 hottest ideas
to start this year you know and try to
do all them you know and you'll fail at
all of them uses end up losing money
where you want to create you want to you
want to be in the business that even if
you weren't making money you would do it
because it makes you come alive but it
fuels you up you know I throw away way
more work than I ever even release I
spent half a day working on the campaign
for one of my clients age that I know
they would never use like it's just it's
too bold it's too big they're too
conservative they would never jump on
this thing but but I had to do it like
it just it was something that creative
that I had to get out i had to express
my art and i sent it to them when
they're like how cool thank you I don't
like I'm not attached to the result I
want to create amazing stuff and I
release it and thankfully a lot of the
videos that I made people do enjoy but I
think people get way too much attached
to the outcome and not the process where
you have to enjoy the process if you
don't enjoy the process you'll never get
to the outcome and so you create the
create like I'm coming on this show
talking to you I don't care what the
result like I want a spread
entrepreneurship and I have a good time
talking to dr. well we're going to talk
genius and potential and
entrepreneurship and you know whether
that explodes or not it doesn't matter
because I'm enjoying like this I hope
you guys watch you can feel my
excitement and passion I love and if you
don't bring that to what you're doing
then there's no way you're ever going to
be great there's no way you're ever
going to really tap into your genius and
doing something that you know
generations later they're still talking
about you yeah that's amazing because I
think the same way right I said you know
what the 50 days yes I'm going to talk
to 50 incredible people whether anybody
shows up or not I'm going
take something away like i'm here with
Evan Carmichael right and so whether
anybody else showed up or not me and
Evan are kicking it right before he goes
to New York so let me ask you this man
because we do have a lot of
entrepreneurs on here and I think a lot
of entrepreneurs miss the opportunity
and they don't really understand the
power of what we're doing right now in
terms of this internet thing like you're
in Toronto I'm in Phoenix Arizona we're
using this black I'm streaming it live
on Facebook you've literally went global
because of your website how powerful is
the internet for businesses today I mean
I think it's the game it's possible to
have a local business without without
internet but man there's so much more
power to tap into I think I think what
holds a lot of people doc is there there
to the perfectionist you know they want
it to be perfect I'm not going to launch
my youtube channel until I get all the
gear and I can afford the right camera
in the tripod and the lighting and all
that stuff meanwhile you know you're
sitting wherever you are I'm sitting
here I've just got a webcam and a
microphone at work we're kicking it you
know I did interviews with Michael
Gerber and collapse of brian tracy and
you know doing addresses I'm here for
500 CEOs to sit here it doesn't matter
about the gear just start like just
start your first thing that you make is
going to suck anyway so don't get so
attached to it the most important thing
is that you're just better than you were
yesterday like every day doing something
new and the next day you're better than
you were the last and so as I said when
we started off man I know that you're
very passionate about entrepreneurs you
can to motivate us inspire us to get us
to the next level if you could if you
could pick out three of your your go-to
moves right now or entrepreneurs what
entrepreneurs in this space thinking
about running how can they change the
grip
I think one is doing something that
you're passionate about doing something
that makes you come alive I think most
people are just kind of walking dead
everybody has an idea but they don't do
anything about it so that's one and
doesn't have to be some big thing just
start like you will you won't know how
it ends DUP it never ends up as you
think it's going to end up but the most
common the company everybody has is that
they started and so you need to start
find the thing you're excited about it
if you lose interest move on and do
something else so follow your passion
number two model success find people who
have done it before and look at how they
got started that's what saved my company
at the start I looked at how successful
entrepreneurs lot started made their
first sale you know I don't care how
successful billionaires now make an
extra billing I want to know like 0 0 2
million like how do i how do I do that
that's what I was really excited by and
and so looking at people in your
industry pad success can be super
helpful as well as people outside your
industry maybe you look up to you know
Oprah Winfrey maybe look up to Bill
Gates you got the Steve Jobs or wealth
is nor any of these guys and me I have
anything to do with your industry but
looking at something that Walt Disney
did might inspire your energy needs to
come out and take some action and so
modeling success I find is super helpful
once you know what is it you want to do
and then the third thing I would say is
create an environment for greatness it's
really hard to do great things when you
have a crappy environment you know when
you have people around who don't support
you think about the movies that you
watch the books you read the websites
you visit you know what people on this
blab watching now they're investing
their time to try to get better right
where other people are just reading the
tabloids or complaining to their friends
about something right like the time that
you spend is important the routine that
you have when you first start your day
is important to have what you have the
people you surround yourself with the
media that you consume it all like
what's on your wall like this is here
for a reason this statue is kind of out
of the picture is there for a reason
like I'm wearing these clothes or I feel
like that man I put on my belief shirt
man
like you got to feel inspired by the
environment around you is you cannot do
great things unless you have greatness
around you man that's powerful now let's
talk about the flip side of this right
let's talk about me and you we're both
positive individuals but let's talk
about how hard and how sucky it is to be
an entrepreneur and how hard it is to
build a business a lot of people don't
talk about that they talk about the
roses but they don't talk about the
thorns how hard is it to build a
business yeah man i'll talk about thorns
all day long man it's the hardest thing
you're ever going to do in your life
it's it's insanely difficult I mean we
don't get it's difficult because one we
don't go to school for this right like I
went to school I went to university went
to the best university of mike in canada
uh you know they don't teach you how to
be an entrepreneur and unless you have
some kind of entrepreneurial background
like your parents or entrepreneurs or
somebody in your family i didn't have
that you know I my dad worked for the
government until he retired you know
like I didn't have any entrepreneurial
people around me so I thought I wanted
to be a banker when I graduated high
school and so it's going to be insanely
hard because all we see are the positive
you see the Zuckerberg some Facebook and
all these guys making a lot of money
having a big impact and then you try you
start you think it's going to be easy
and it's not and and it's devastating
and you realize that you're way out of
your league and you feel like you know
you're trying to add value and it's not
for lack of hustle like you're hustling
you're putting in the work and you're
still not seeing results and that's
where the passion is important because
that's he listened it gets you through
because because any logical sane person
would quit because it's just too
difficult but you only keep going
because you love the process of what
you're doing I will keep doing this even
if I never get paid because I love it so
much and most people don't love their
thing enough and they're just trying to
chase an opportunity like you want to
start a YouTube channel to be a
celebrity and get famous like it's not
going to happen you gotta love making
YouTube videos and you gotta love the
product that you're selling and man you
traction there's a story and a reason
behind it and that's if that's not
emotional love for you then there's no
way you're going to stick it out like
soon as it gets hard that's it you're
done you're gonna do something else man
you've given us so much stuff and I want
to talk about this because a lot of
people a lot of entrepreneurs ask me
this or this becomes a a holding back
talk about your team a lot of times when
we see people like you we're thinking
like you have this big hundred member
team and you're downtown Toronto in this
big executive office talk to us about
your team and how you built out your
Evan Carmichael team sure um you know
when I started my first business that
there was three partners that's it we
had nobody on our team it was the free
of us just grinding every day I was
working three hundred dollars a month
man like you can't afford t make it
three hundred dollars enough and I
couldn't afford to feed myself let alone
feed anybody else ah now my team is what
16 people um after I sold my business
the first company started Evan
Carmichael calm I actually negotiated
free downtown rent king and young is is
the epicenter of downtown straw and all
the financial buildings and I gots lead
location there by partnering up with two
with the with an angel and venture
capitalist firm there and I agreed to
help them out and they gave me
mentorship and a place to work and the
first person that hired in my company
you know he needed an hour a day of work
most people think you gotta hire
somebody whole time you know the guy I
got a free up 30 40 50 60 thousand
dollars a hire somebody full time to
help me listen how it works man hire
somebody for an hour a day if you were
before you and that freed up more than
an hour of my time per day to do it was
because he was better at that job than I
was for you to have success you to
really tap into your genius and realize
it and make it something special then
you have to spend as much time on your
genius as possible right if you are a
genius at doing something but you're
spending 99% of your time all this other
then we're going to really worry you
need to go until you start eliminated
automating delegating some of the other
clip away as far as much time as
possible on your bones and so that was
the first guy I hired when our debut did
database work for me and got some ideas
man that's amazing so now um for you
what's the next what's the next thing
for Evan Carmichael what do you work
your know and I know you're traveling
the world getting ready to hop on a
plane in New York and spread more your
message about believe what's the overall
what's the big what's the big go for
what's pushing you right now what's
motivating you ah my big goal is help a
billion entrepreneurs that's that's my
that's my mission so I'm shooting on the
shorter term goals is I want to hit a
million subscribers on my youtube
channel and I'm writing a book and
that's coming out december six uh beyond
that I don't know man like when I want
to do something I do it I just start I
don't have like here's what I'm gonna be
in five years you know that kind of
thinking bothers me like if I have a
five year goal like why can't I do that
in three months why does it have to take
five years to hit that and so you know
and that happens in across my life like
I thought you know I want to build a
house I'm going to build a custom house
you know some might lists one of the
things to do and as soon as I thought
entered my head now I'm looking for
house I'm looking for land and you know
I found on the plot and I dug up you
know the excavation I build the house
you know we're going to eater of
thinking of me wanting to buy a house to
build more so I where we're going to be
in five meters i have no idea man and
somewhere alive that's just my
personality but i don't have long-term
things and gets in my head and it's a
[ __ ] if you don't want to take action
on it right away then it's not that a
pointy like maybe need or inspiring doll
that makes you come alive all this has
got you man now here's probably going to
be the toughest question of the day you
have a whole way
site of motivation and inspiration and
you've interviewed over thousands
quality of entrepreneurs and you talked
to all the movers and shakers but if you
had to narrow it down to light the three
top people that like your go-to team
like what you're starting five who would
be your starting five of motivation like
when Evan needs to really get pumped up
who does he listen to in his ipod ooh
who's your starting by that's a great
question ah I feel like I go to
different people with different things
so right on my five I totally hot or to
leadership hmm leadership that's an
interesting one i'll give you my top
five and I like him with different
reasons I'll go with uh Walt Disney
Steve Jobs Kanye West Richard Branson
and my parents it wasn't my top five ok
so I have been actually this Kanye what
are you go to Kanye Kanye is unafraid
haha yay Kanye first of all says a lot
of a lot of crazy things a lot of things
I don't agree with a lot of his actions
I may not agree with but he is not
afraid oh he's not afraid to do it I
stop what is really and look at how was
jump like honey a lot of try to do it as
one for me a while to anybody for his
age in the history of ever right and now
he's like you know music I'm gonna do
stills also do some of that but I want
to be a fashion designer right and he
started off just just being the beads
guy and remember T like people people
like shakily he can only do this they
put him inside his body no man that's
not my but I'm jumping I'm gonna do
something else and so a lot of the guys
like speed drops to you may not look to
as a guy as like he could be a real dick
to a lot of people and stuff like right
what I want to do is I want to pull
different
to be the best version of myself I don't
want to be the next con grat you next to
the jobs are next anybody I want to be
the best Evan Carmichael and to do that
I'm going to pull a piece from konyen
full of piece of radiation are getting
jobs and people who like they kick from
somebody they may hate that person you
still learn from them um a lot of people
hate on Trump and and Trump has a lot of
just ridiculous things but but you could
learn a lot from him to you know the way
as he presents big ideas like you can
you know what his ideas aren't you if
you don't agree with them so I'm not
afraid to learn from a novel
controversial people oh I'm just pulling
a piece from them not everything dig it
man I dig it man man this has been a
fascinating 30 minutes man I appreciate
you being here I know you got to catch a
flight to New York I'm not gonna hold
you up man but quickly you really don't
have to say it but everybody just knows
is Evan Carmichael calm you can find out
more about Evan there and I strongly
suggest that everybody follow Evan
everybody go to his platforms be a part
of his platforms like I said at the
beginning his platform was one of the
major platforms that I used to get my
message about living genius out and it's
been a tremendous a tremendous blessing
for me so Evan thank you for carving out
sometime man to be with us man i really
appreciate you thanks man and I
appreciate you man spreading the love
out of energy and fire to enter your
community encouraging people to follow
their genius if everybody did that the
world would be a pretty special place it
sure would man hey everybody thank you
guys so much for joining me today
remember tomorrow same time our guests
will be the phenomenal forbes riley the
car heard the two billion dollar lady
she is the promoter of the spin gym so
she'll be with us tomorrow i'm excited
to have her just like i was excited to
have evidence all the other special
guests here on the 50 days of genius so
check us out tomorrow we'll be back for
50 days of genius signing off
guys talk to you tomorrow